so the mic is working good morning
everyone fled the heavier and I'm glad
to be here we're going to start talking
about your pretty simple ideas of what
is the what is our atmosphere what is
what it mean when we say air what are we
talking about and then we'll gradually
build up and I want to give you by the
end of the period a little bit of idea
of what kind of research we do studying
the atmosphere the physics of the
atmosphere so let's see where will we
start I'm going to be guided by this
over here of course there's the earth
and it's a covered with a layer of air
and in the atmosphere in that layer of
air there are some clouds and of course
that's what you're seeing a mixture of
clear air and clouds and we'll be
getting closer to that by the end of the
period looking at clear air and clouds
let me start with us so I'm going to be
asking you kids a few questions this
morning and I need to hear those answers
loud and clear so let's just do a
practice run on that if I say is
something true and it is true you're
going to say yes and you're going to
raise your hand together shove it up and
raise your hand 13 yes there you go okay
I want to hear that loud and clear
because some of the times you're going
to be right in some of the times maybe
you're going to be wrong let's start
with this one so what is the air what is
the atmosphere now first choice you have
is that those two words air and
atmosphere describe the nothingness
around us I don't see the air I see you
guys out there I don't see the air I
don't smell anything
I don't feel anything so it may be
there's just nothing there and that's
one option the other option is that
those words they're an atmosphere
described some kind of a gas whatever
that word means gasps held to the Earth
by the Earth's gravity now how many
believe in number one okay we got a few
and how many believe in number two okay
number two has it but you know I think
number two is right I think you guys are
right but you've got some explaining to
do because why is it that I don't see
anything and I don't smell anything and
I don't feel anything so we're going to
work on that but maybe you guys are
right but I'm not sure about that we'll
see as we go along now how do we know
what atmosphere is present now I noticed
when I came in you guys are already
doing some nice experiments yeah that
would give you the answer to these
questions but I'm going to do a few
other really simple experiments up here
and the first one would just be trying
to see how fast a piece of paper would
drop now if there were no atmosphere in
this room that would drop like a rock
and you'd hear it go bang when it hits
the floor but in fact it goes down
pretty slowly that's an indication that
there's something here and whatever that
thing is it's got some mass is
preventing that air from just that paper
from just dropping now a paper airplane
if there's no hair in this room
obviously it's not going to fly let's
see if it does yeah works pretty well so
there must be something here it can't be
nothing that is that something's holding
up there
well when the really windy outside was a
couple days ago you feel that wind
hitting you it actually pushes you
around so something with mass is hitting
you and pushing you around I mean I can
demonstrate it here a little bit and I
noticed out in the hall there you had
this wonderful little air gun did
everybody get to try lihue tried that
air gun out there wasn't that cool so it
made a little jet of air that knocked
over some cups and that was a real nice
proof that there's something here that's
moving around and it has mass now well
obviously number four you know if it
wasn't any air in this room you wouldn't
be able to hear me talking and I
wouldn't be able to hear you so when I
do this and you can hear it that means
that sound is propagating through the
air Sam cannot propagate in a vacuum if
there's nothing there that sound can't
reach you so you know there's air for
that reason well this would be the time
to take a casual a little drink of water
but I've got a straw that I'm drinking
the water through and that's good but
what's going on with that work but I'm
be able to drink through a straw if
there were no atmosphere what's the
answer yes or no no because what's
happening is that the air pressure is
getting down into that bottle pressing
down on the surface of the water and
then that's what's pushing it up the
straw all I'm doing is reducing the
pressure a little bit there still
pressure at the top I'm just reducing it
a little bit to allow that atmospheric
pressure to push the water up the tube
so when you see me here casually
drinking that too is proof that there's
something in this
that has weight and it has pressure so
I'm trying to overwhelm you with
evidence because I don't see anything so
we need to prove that there's something
here okay I notice outside there were
some suction cups I need a couple of
volunteers continue guys come forward
and just try to pull these apart for me
come I don't know stand here and watch
out because you know if they let go
you're going to fall maybe but he's take
one of those now remember let me just
take a second these aren't sticky
there's no glue in there so the only
thing that's going to hold them apart is
the fact that i'm removing the air from
inside but you've still got the air
pressure pushing on the outside it's the
same air pressure that i was using to
drink this so let's see let's get these
lined up a little bitter I'll just pull
us apart for me
now those are either really weak kids
and I don't four or there's a lot of air
pressure in the room okay you guys have
done well that's excellent thanks very
much so I think we're closing in on this
maybe I almost had you convinced that
there's something in this room and if
you still don't believe it when you go
outside this morning and look up get
outside that door on the way out you're
going to see some clouds and maybe some
blue sky and that blue of course is sun
light being scattered to your eye by the
air molecules if there was no atmosphere
and you looked up it would just be black
now if you ever climbed to the top of a
very high mountain like Mount Everest
and you look up you're already above
most of the atmosphere not much air
above you and so when you look up you
don't see blue you just see black so
that blue sky is also telling you that
there's atmosphere up there okay I think
we've got that one surrounded also by
the way when you are up in a satellite
and you look down at Earth you see this
little fuzzy blue layer there it's not
very thick compared to the radius of the
earth but that's the atmosphere that's
the Earth's atmosphere so that's some
additional evidence now here's a
question for you guys what would happen
I've already you've already told me and
I think you were correct that the
atmosphere is a gas held to our planet
by the gravity field of our plan just
like you and I are held down by the
gravity of the planet well what would
happen oh this is just a thought
experiment this wouldn't couldn't really
have
and practice but what would happen if we
suddenly turned off granted i'm going to
give you two options here you company
which one you think is right i suddenly
turn off earth gravity our bodies would
suddenly shoot up off the planet or the
atmosphere would explode upwards leaving
us just sitting behind okay you got
those two options how many think that
it's number one in the area okay how
many think it's number two it's about an
even split well here's what I think
would happen I think it'd be number two
because the atmosphere is held down by
the gravity field kind of like the air
in your tire is held in by the rubber of
the tire and if i were to puncture that
tire that air gas would explode out
words if i were to puncture that balloon
you get an explosion out whatever is
holding that if I suddenly remove it it
will explode upwards whereas we were
massive we're not a gas a compressible
gas so we would just be standing there
on earth and boom the atmosphere would
be gone and we'd be looking around
saying what in the world just happened
so it's number two is the right answer
now I have to follow that question with
this one which is kind of a natural
extension of that last question so the
atmosphere would be gone in a
instant and I think you know that we
depend on our atmosphere to keep us
alive in many different ways the
atmosphere is our friend but the way I'm
posing the question here is not would
the lack of an atmosphere kill us answer
to that is yes but what would kill us
first what aspect of missing the
atmosphere would kill us first number
one we would be hit by cosmic rays and
ultraviolet radiation that is normally
stopped by the atmosphere so they don't
hit us that's a very important role for
the atmosphere also there are a lot of
small little meteorites in space moving
at an enormous rate of speed when they
come into the atmosphere they burn up
before they hit us and we are protected
by the atmosphere of from those little
meteorites number three without this
atmospheric pressure we've been
demonstrating our blood would boil you
know that when you go to high altitude
when you if you boil water at sea level
it's 212 Fahrenheit 100 degrees Celsius
if you go up to the top of Pikes Peak in
Colorado and boil water it boils have a
considerably lower temperature if you
are up to Mount Everest it would boil
and even a lower temperature below the
pressure the lower is the boiling
temperature of water well if I removed
the air pressure completely that might
change the boiling temperature and put
it down in the range of what my body
temperature normal is that's what i mean
by number three and number four would be
we would suffocate because every every
minute or so every happen
I'm taking in a breath putting it out
using the oxygen to keep my circulatory
system going on my metabolism going so
we depend on the atmosphere for all
those things they would all do us in we
didn't have it but which one would come
first so how many think it would be
number one a few shout it out loud get
your hand up okay I may think would be
number two somebody in the back good for
you how about number three yes quite a
few answers on that what about number
four yeah okay number four as the
majority but number three is the right
answer
our blood would boil instantly and we
would die after say a very excruciating
debt something like if you you know many
scuba divers ask them about something
called the fan miss if you've been down
diving and your blood gets saturated the
gas and then you suddenly pop to the
surface your blood boils and you die a
very agonizing death sorry to bring that
into your saturday morning don't worry
it's not going to happen that's the last
thing you have to worry about okay see
we're beginning to understand something
about the atmosphere that's good now I
want to turn to this question of
balloons because I want to talk to you
about how weather balloons are used to
study the atmosphere and I can't do that
if you don't understand why weather
balloon goes up in the atmosphere these
are helium-filled balloons and they
definitely want to go up I've got them
tied to a string I had an adventure
coming over here I filled up a big red
helium balloon and I tried it once and i
lost it helping the sky i tried it again
and i made it right to that door and it
popped as i came in the door and Kurt
was kind enough to blow these up for me
so at least I have some kind of a helium
balloon to show you but I want to do an
experiment well maybe we'll able to get
some answers on this first and then I'll
do the experiment so Jillian filled the
balloon does tend to rise you see it
there is it because gravity does not act
on that balloon or is it because there's
some kind of invisible string up here
pulling it upwards that I can't see or
is it because the balloon filled with
helium has something called a buoyancy
force acting on it okay those are your
three options how many think it's number
one
number two yes okay number two thank you
now that string may be there but I don't
find it and how about number three I
guess that one was too easy but what
okay you like that you like that
explanation because it sounds more
technically it's got a term in their
buoyancy force and you know what that
means if it well I'll go with that one
because that's a that's a technical the
technical sounding answer but what is
this thing called the buoyancy force
well i'm going to describe it a couple
times and then we're going to do an
experiment to see if it's really true
suddenly a buoyancy force you know as
you go up in the atmosphere order you
mentioned this is to go up in the
atmosphere the air pressure gets less
and less and less eventually you get
outside the atmosphere and there's no
air pressure at all now if the air
pressure decreases as you go up in the
atmosphere that means that at the bottom
of those balloons the air pressure is a
little bit greater than at the top of
those booms so the air pressure pushing
up here is a little bit greater than the
air pushing down there that may surprise
you is if that makes any difference
because that's not a very great distance
is it that's only 10 or 20 centimeters
but that actually is the origin of the
buoyancy force that really is why those
balloons are trying to rise is because
the air pressure there is a little bit
greater than the air pressure there now
I'm kind of demonstration you just see
what
yeah so anything you do come what I've
just told you does the balloon have a
greater mass or weight when I blow it up
I'm going to do this experiment for you
I'm going to weigh a balloon then I'm
going to blow it up with air we're going
to weigh it again and we're going to see
if it weighs anything different so
before I do it let me just get some
answers on this one Curtis being
technically number one no when I blow up
a balloon with air it does not change
its late number two when I blow up a
balloon with air weighs more or number
three yes again when I will blow up the
balloon with air its mass and weight
changes but this change is exactly
canceled by the buoyancy force so let's
this is the more technical one they've
been more difficult let's get some
answers how many think number one when I
blow up the balloon with air it does not
change its weight okay a lot of good
answers their number two when I blow up
the balloon it weighs more we've got
some answers there and what about yes
also yes when I blow up a balloon there
it does increase it to mass in its
weight but that is canceled by the
buoyancy force what if you like that one
but there was a hesitation I could see
you thinking there well now I've got it
examined and I hope this works I have a
balloon
and I'm going to weigh the balloon I've
got this box up here now the scale Oh to
see the numbers I'm not sure that's
going to work because I'm now it's like
I said I've got i'll have to read the
number offer you let me just put this up
so i can write on the board
okay so I've set that you've all used a
scale before I've set this to 0 with the
Box on there so I'm going to weigh the
balloon and it weighs 33 grams as a mass
at 33 grams and now i'm going to try
well i better be careful here i have to
tie this string off and i want to be a
good scientist and do things carefully
so I better way the string that I'm
going to use to hold on
who see that made a difference so i'm
going to say 36 grams with a string now
i'm going to blow this balloon up I hope
Kurt if I faint away because you can
finish it's a big balloon so it's going
to take me a couple minutes to do this
see you guys can just doze off
a long ways to go by the way I know that
if I blow this up to about that size I
will have put about 60 grams about 60
grams of area there if i can get it
blown up to a good size shutting off on
me
my dog's gonna take a while
moon keeps collapsing
I'm almost there I want to get a bigger
though for you
okay that should do it whatever going to
tie this off can you help you just tie
that off for a second with a string I've
got the inside so I put in about 60
grams of air in there and we're going to
weigh this again
that is reading 36.5 and yet I have put
in approximately 60 grams of air well
that's very curious i know that if i add
other things to the box i can add the
weight but yet when i put air in this
balloon a lot of air in that balloon it
doesn't seem to have changed the weight
of that at all so well the answer is
number three i added mass by putting the
air in there but now I've made the
balloon bigger so the pressure
difference between the bottom of the top
is now bigger so there's a buoyancy
force on that balloon that was not there
before and that's why I'm getting no
change in weight so that's the idea
behind the buoyancy force the bigger the
object is the bit of the balloon is the
more buoyancy forces and if I fill it
with air there's always going to be
exactly that cancellation however mass
how much mass I put in there the
buoyancy force is going to exactly
cancel it but when I fill it with helium
because helium is a lighter gas I get an
increase in buoyancy force that's
greater than the mass that I put inside
the blue and that's why there's a net
buoyancy force on that balloon to make
it go up it up so that's the idea there
I think that's clearly
so there's the idea behind the buoyancy
force the air pressure decreases with
height so there's a greater pressure on
the bottom in the top the difference is
called the buoyancy force and the bigger
the balloon the bigger is the buoyancy
force and if I fill it with air those
two things cancel the weight of the
balloon of the air that I put in and the
buoyancy force is exactly cancer okay
we're ready to move on now oh by the way
this buoyancy force you have experienced
this yourself because when you're
swimming you're being held up by the
water and it's exactly the buoyancy
force the pressure on your belly is a
little bit greater than the pressure on
your back in the water and that's what
keeps you floating in the water and so
you've experienced that in water but now
you understand that this happens in air
as well because like water air has mass
and air has weight so if it's a pointy
force on any object that is in it now
we're ready to talk about weather
balloons as a meteorologist I get a lot
of my information about the atmosphere
from weather balloons and here's a few
facts hundreds of weather balloons are
launched each day from stations around
the world as they rise up through the
atmosphere they're carrying a little
instrument package here's one that I
brought along it measures temperature
humidity it's got a radio antenna so it
can radio that information back and by
seeing how it drips with the wind we can
measure the wind speed and direction as
a function of height so it's just a
helium balloon with that little
instrument package under
and we get information about wind
temperature and humidity that
information is used to understand the
atmosphere and predict the weather by
the way like I say there are hundreds of
these launched every day they take about
two hours to go up to about 20 miles
then the balloon breaks and they fall
back to earth and they're never found
and never reused and occasionally
somebody will find one and there is a
little note on here it says please
return to the weather bureau if you find
this very few people ever do but is
anybody here ever seen one of these
things never found one no this is a bit
surprising because there's so many have
been launched over so many years and yet
I've only come across one or two in my
lifetime and just by accident most of
them fall in the ocean okay so that's
what it looks like helium balloon bigger
than the ones we have here there's the
instrument package he's holding it there
there's a little parachute so it when it
falls back to earth it doesn't fall fast
enough that it would hurt anybody when
it when it comes back to the Earth's
surface and these are the stations where
weather balloons are launched twice a
day every day for the last 50 years
weather services around the around the
world in all those different countries
have been launching their weather
balloons and that data by the way goes
into your daily weather forecast that's
how we broadcast
that's how we forecast the weather now
what kind of data do we get from that
this morning I went online to get the
data from the balloon soundings that
whirl and launching yesterday evening
the launch was that word eastern
standard time the launch was at seven
p.m. last night and this is some data
from the closest balloon launching
station to us it's just across Long
Island Sound on Long Island it's a
little town called upton and what's
plotted here is temperature on this axis
altitude or pressure decreasing as you
go up this black line is temperature
this black line is dew point dewpoint
tells you something about how much water
vapor there is in the atmosphere and
then over here on the right hand side is
the wind information presented to you
with a little of thing a meteorologist
calls a wind bar it's a little diagram
you draw a little symbol that you draw
the direction tells you the wind is what
attraction wind is blowing in and the
number of feathers tells you how fast
the wind is blowing for example that's a
20 not when 50-knot wind 50-knot wind is
the thick one so 65 70 70 65 those are
those units are at knotts they be
slightly greater in miles per hour for
example a 79 wind is about an e5 mile
per hour wind that's a pretty good win
now that's way up above the Earth's
atmosphere surface that's probably three
or four miles up in the atmosphere and
then I went to another station
down in northern florida i went to the
Tallahassee station anybody been to
Florida buddy tell ask anybody you know
where it is right it's in northern
Florida and there's the sounding
launched the same time it from a
different city temperature altitude
let's just look over here at that wind
my goodness we've got 150 knots we've
got 160 knots that's about a hundred and
eighty miles per hour up there 180 miles
per hour that wound is moving now one of
the things because all those of all the
balloons are launched simultaneously
they rise together around the world you
can make a map an instantaneous map of
the winds at any altitude that you want
and here's what it looks like for that
moment last night let me tell you where
you are you're Splore it up here's New
Haven Connecticut there's the Upton data
that I gave you and there's the
Tallahassee data that I gave you now
this color coding is described down here
in knots and look at that there's a jet
stream coming across the northern part
of our country swinging software and
then accelerating again getting up to
speeds in excess of 150 knots blowing
west to east like say that's a speed of
about 180 miles an hour it's fast
passionate and this is what weather
balloons can do for you they can tell
you what the way that all out to zone or
like and by the way if you fly on a
commercial airliner American Airlines
Delta this is about the altitude that
they fly in so I bet the pilots are
looking at that map and saying well if
I'm going west to east I'm going to get
my airplane right into that
jet and get a free ride but if I'm going
east to west I better take a different
route I better come like this or I
better come like this because I'm not
going to want to go right against that
180 mile an hour wind coming right in my
face I'll burn up a lot more fuel it
will add an hour or two to my flight and
so the pilots take a very close look at
this and they get their data the same
way i have here they get it from the
from the weather balloons the daily the
daily weather okay now we're getting on
in time so i got to wrap up the PM the
last thing i want to talk about is
research aircraft because this is
another way that we understand and do
research on the atmosphere remember all
the weather balloon does is temperature
humidity and wind well there's a lot of
other things we'd like to know about the
atmosphere but we can't get the
instruments for that to go on on the
device like this and just be thrown away
instead we put them on a research
aircraft there's a research aircraft
that I've used recently in one of my
projects it looks a bit like a normal
airplane except if you look closely it's
got a nose boom with some instruments
out there and then it's got some
instruments under the wing as well and
inside it's loaded with computers and
scientists so this is what we use to do
atmospheric research now I have to
remember since I've told you about the
weather balloon what holds the airplane
up it's not buoyancy but it's something
related to buoyancy because the air has
to go rapidly over the wing of the
airplane you get high pressure below and
low pressure above in this case because
the airplane is moving so rapidly and
that produces something called lift that
keeps up a little bit different than
buoyancy because buoyancy you don't have
to be mu
through the air there you do so we call
it lift instead of buoyancy but that
pressure difference helps to keep the
airplane up in the atmosphere now what
about these instruments that scientists
use here's a one of the wing tips of
this aircraft this is the king air and
there's some devices under here that
measure a variety of things but
especially they measure particles in the
atmosphere dust particles we call those
aerosols or cloud particles or even
raindrops to happen to fly through a
range shaft it'll measure the raindrops
as well here's a list of some of those
incidents remember these three can be
done on balloons but not the rest of
these and also on the aircraft we have
some remote sensing devices we've got
radar that can send a microwave signal
out and get the echo coming back telling
us about raindrops we've got light are
basically a laser that goes out and
scatters back giving us information
about dust in the atmosphere so on one
of our flights in this recent project
there was our little crew it's a pretty
small airplane you've got the pilot
you've got the data guy you've got the
chief scientist and you've got that's my
student Allison who was sitting in the
front on this particular day there she
is taking notes she's got a data screens
in front of her you can't see it where
all the data is coming out on a computer
screen I'm sitting in the back I've got
one of those computer screens too and
the pilot is can't see these on the left
there so looking out the front window
that's what you see there's a nose boom
and we're seeing some pods up that we're
going to fly through those clouds
there's another student on a different
flight looking happy in the back seat
and take him some pictures out the
window and there's the data is coming
out on his little computer screen here
and that's looking out the left wing go
that's what he's seeing as it takes that
photograph he's seeing some of the
instruments on that wing tip and he's
also seeing some big clouds that were
flying by that we're going to penetrate
and there's a view out the right window
again there's an island there's the
ocean for some clouds and there's some
more instruments under the right wing
tip now we're just about to penetrate
that cloud and what did we find when we
penetrated that Club well this is the
kind of data that we we gather on these
research missions so let me explain what
spot of you you know when clouds form
the droplets are very tiny they're not
large enough to fall to earth or not
raindrops we call them cloud droplets
you say drop left because that suffix
let indicates it's kind of a small
little guy right so a cloud droplet is
what we're measuring you there's a
diameter the units are in microns now a
micron is a millionth of a meter it's a
thousandth of a millimeter and for some
of the flights for Pep on one of the
flights by the way in this axis is the
number of particles we found with each
of these different droplet sizes on one
of the flights we found rather large
droplets typically 20 to 25 microns that
was on a day when the air was rather
clean with very little dust and air
assault in it on another day when there
was a lot of dust in the atmosphere to
begin with the cloud droplets were a lot
smaller a reason for that is of course
the cloud droplets form
articles so if you got the same amount
of water to be condensed if you put them
on a lot of droplets a lot of dust
particles they're going to be small if
you put them on a few dust particles
they're going to be larger this then
will be the situation that can lead to
precipitation because these larger
droplets start to collide with each
other and merging and after that happens
a few dozen times you can build a
raindrop and it falls to earth whereas
you could not get this cloud Department
to precipitate because the droplets are
just too small to hit each other and
they won't get that process going where
they can form a raindrop so that gives
you a bit of an introduction atmospheric
research I'll leave you with this if you
want to be at atmospheric scientist when
you grow up these are some of the
questions that you will be asking you we
are asking today about clouds in the
atmosphere how bigger bigger the cloud
droplets how many cod profits are there
is the cloud raining why or why not are
the cloud particle made of liquid water
or are they nice how do the cottage the
cloud reflect sunlight and does that
cause the earth to be cooler than it
would be without the clouds that's a
very important question in this day of
climate change what role are clouds
playing in controlling the temperature
of the earth are the clouds cleaning the
atmosphere by collecting dust particles
and then raining them out and finally
how well clouds change if the earth
becomes warmer as we think is going to
do so I'll leave you there and thanks
for your attention
you